hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the brand new iphone se i'm
so excited i can't wait to check this
out i love the iphone se now as my
personal phone i do always go for the
pro max versions but the fact that this
phone is one of the only ones that still
has that home button and with touch id
is something i think that a lot of
iphone users do love and some of us
might even miss so before we get into
the specs let's unbox it
[Music]
hello little phone
oh
it's the starlight
look how pretty
i didn't even know what color i had this
is
so great
wow
check
that out
look at that fingerprint button right
there just letting you know
touch id
this is also something that i've never
noticed before i don't know if that's
because they kind of feel like this is
more of a beginner phone that they have
the buttons labeled on each side of like
what the things are touch id
power button
mute volume up volume down
i don't
think that they do that on any other pro
devices so that's actually kind of
interesting and this isn't really a
beginner phone but maybe they just
assume that this is like somebody's
first phone and maybe they don't
understand i don't know they even
labeled the charging port here we go
are you ready
oh oh oh other side
love that also in the box we've got our
power cable
and the sticker and sim card ejector
we've also got a case and this is the
abyss blue
that's pretty it's gonna look great on
the starlight
oh that's nice
do they have an apple watch band in this
color because if they do
call me what a nice little phone like
this is incredible it's so light let's
get it all set up and head outside
here it is set up touch id let's do it
look at this oh this is great
what a happy
time
[Music]
all right it's all set up let's head
outside and test it out so no phone
review is complete without testing out
the video so first let's do some
front-facing video and see how this
performs all right
hello hi it's justine here coming to you
live from the coffee bean tea leaf we're
gonna take a sip
[Music]
the colors look nice we're shooting in
4k at 30 frames a second on the front
facing camera now let's flip over to the
rear camera what's up friends okay so
i'm using the single camera here on the
iphone se how does it sound how does it
look
[Music]
gotta do the hair flips my shoes
they're furry
great love that now let's test out the
photos we're gonna take a portrait mode
photo and then jake is gonna take a
portrait well not portrait a normal
photo with his actual camera and room
with them side by side and see what they
look like here you go
[Music]
i mean it's still so impressive like
what this little phone and camera can do
i mean yeah obviously it's not perfect
still is pretty good i love the colors
on that good job little phone so the
iphone sc is a pretty big improvement
over the previous and it even pulls some
specs from the iphone 13. like the a15
bionic chip it also now has 5g it's got
a glass front and back the camera system
is improved with a 12 megapixel camera
with computational photography deep
fusion and smart hdr it has a 4.7 inch
retina hd display it has improved
battery life 16 core neural engine
improved video quality it's 26 times
faster than an iphone 8 and it comes in
three new colors as for pricing it
starts at 429
so after using this phone for a little
bit it kind of reminded me that not
everyone needs to have the highest end
iphone because this while it is nowhere
near the stats and the specs of the pro
max
it's an incredible little device for
most people if you just want to take
some photos and some videos and have a
powerful enough device to be able to
view those photos edit those photos talk
to your friends facetime you can play
video games like this is
it's kind of like a perfect phone i
definitely enjoyed getting a chance to
check this out because i feel like
sometimes i do get a little bit jaded by
just testing out things that are the
highest end and that's not realistic for
most people because most people do not
need that high end of a phone so it is
kind of cool to kind of bring it back
and kind of test out phones that really
make more sense for most people and this
se can kind of be sort of like your
entryway into the apple ecosystem if
you're coming from android or if your
grandmother or parents you don't want to
start them on the highest end iphones
like this can be a perfect start for
them it has everything you need it is
even using parts from the new iphone 13
like the a15 bionic chip it does have 5g
so really this is all that you would
need so if you guys are new here thank
you so much for watching and if you
haven't already be sure to subscribe and
hit the bell so you'll be notified when
i post new videos i have a bunch of
reviews coming up so i look forward to
sharing those with you so with that i
will see you in my next video
and also did you guys know that you can
use phones
to make phone calls
yeah i know you can do that on here
little phone
you're cute i like you a lot
[Music]